hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play yet we've just got a sub
objective completed I'm not exactly sure
what but I got enough to get out of here
I think I'm starting to understand that
in higher difficulties you would need
the enemies because with the number they
throw in you yeah especially the quick
ones in tight corners you need to be
able to stop
I can see why they have all those states
don't even try it
I don't know why you went away that
would've been the perfect time to try to
kill me I mean I'm in enclosed space you
got an explosive device on your arm why
not would you try to rat on it can't
touch yes
okay now where am I go we're here back
to the crazy guy no not back to the
crazy guy the other way to go
[Applause]
bodies are still here Oh back through
the to the basketball court or something
just to make you guys happy and just
because I want a little variety
I'm gonna get a new weapon and I'm gonna
get this contact beam because I've been
thinking about it this seems like the
biggest gun and I want Dillon biggest
gun yeah
contact energy only one per be like yeah
it should be good
contact energy stacks up for you know
use it on I'll use it when I find
another big guy he's not a big guy
that's what I'm gonna use hope you enjoy
it it's gonna be maybe epic looks like
it lines up like the cutter but I don't
know whatever to leave it to hello Oh
with that with that
thank you ooh more contact energy
perfect
oh I got luck either got kruky thought
something was coming down the elevator
faith whose dog was that the crazy guy
that's crazy
so you will be beyond any physical
concerns fools this is what we'll be
searching for all these years
okay this is what we have been waiting
for don't listen to them come back yes
everyone comes you crazy turning away
from the church at this vital hour do
not abandon your faith what's happening
on the colony is not a tragedy god this
truth is even more fantastic doors here
I don't plan other battles
is unfolding ambience inheritors
anything more contacted yet as expensive
[Applause]
sperm ation are no more contacted yeah
contact energy out the hoo-ha oh shut up
guy Todd wants to hear you oh what's
that
yeah free Ruby semiconductor heck yes
back off get some
couldn't be easy I would be out hate to
sleep someone come by move you in your
sleep
ah I can finally I'm out of earshot of
that crazy dude I don't seem so good oh
no oh boy of course everyone lives just
long enough to kill themselves in front
of Isaac I'm guessing everyone in here
blew their head off why can I see like
that just appear at random times in the
distance ups are Lee up there we go yes
finally objective complete
hey no no no I'm almost out of station
hahahaha yeah get away no I I mean not
bad no I just wasted the last of my
spacers phenomenal
I knew it was too quiet the music was
not there ah wants to eat my brain I'll
trap you
ah
ah
I got stuff to do
I'll let this proton
where'd you get my watch stopped what
the hell
it didn't do anything okay let's try
this again
was it that was it ah okay try this one
more time got a wicked loan charge up ah
there we go
well you can kill you
damn lady I think be careful with doctor
kind a lot of what I've discovered so
far has come from his record clearly got
insane
he might be unstable maybe even violent
you know whatever I can take care of I
can take on dr. Mercer's amazing evil
bastard of a monster then I can probably
take care of myself who's a scientist
plus I got the armor on Oh dr. Jason I
need to use one of those if I don't find
once I got lots of contact energy now
but man this is whip easy just because
it's not upgraded is that the problem I
mean now that I think about I could have
gotten this out so let me look let me
look on the bench see what I can figure
this thing I'm not gonna sell it back
I'm just gonna keep trying but contact
beam I gotta go through two empty nose
just to get to the beginning
- the first damage agreed the charge by
negative point o seconds yeah that's its
charge of time it's kinda crap I'll hold
off there weren't even that many damage
upgrades okay before I do anything
drastic
okay now go talk to the other guys the
totally same scientist who is somehow
survived on this ship hello you want try
something buddy yes following you
progress huh huh I know you want to
repair these shuttle shock when dry is
destroyed do I never lose holders at
first I almost
[ __ ] some types of systems change the
church they think they're marketed
divine but they don't know what's
happened here what's been released
Wow
that is what we found in the core of the
planet
Merson halted the high mind is the
source controlling the nectar most
fantastic sounds good feels I'm gonna
kill it
man [ __ ] it ago she knew she the marker
was containing it within the plant
returned the marker and feel the hive
mind uh-huh please I'm sorry
Amelia I bet much the responsibility for
this tragedy no I'm gonna take
responsibility for ending it uh-huh
atone for my sins all right but you can
help me if you wouldn't have a shuttle
and bring the marker back on board
that's good to me you do seem to be the
most same person the only person
actually trying to stop this so I guess
I'll follow you
he I mean he see you he I think was a
member of the church I think and now
he's saying in the church and he still
sees a dead person so what's causing
that okay hello
are these the captain's or the officers
of the ship
probably
really really instead of a monkey I'm
gonna do so much yes now
okay all the way
obviously if I missed the contact
I'm out are you son of a [ __ ] don't
make me miss boom oh you don't want to
go
now I'm getting the content all right
this is okay now I'm sure if I upgraded
to Fabia one big bucks but I do have to
cut him in the limbs what's the
alternative is wasted a bullet but that
was
I don't know what I'm gonna explore a
bit before I do that actually I'm out of
time for this episode so I gotta cut it
here thank you guys so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part bye bye